[Music]
all right let's talk about the use of
supe when it comes to delivering a
scheme so supa is a sliding action it's
this action right here like this is I'm
pulling a weapon back a lot of times if
you've done a lot of weapons work in
Aikido particularly one weapons work you
proceed every ski every thrust with a
svet so every ski looks like so that ski
first of all that's not the only way it
has to be delivered if you look at old
footage of Yeosu but you will see him
doing two things when he trusts
sometimes he does Sabet ski sometimes he
does a very direct ski right so right
from here boom thrusting out immediately
and not not drawing the weapon back at
all so why would both of those exist
there's some myth and folklore I don't
believe any of it that has to do with
that more powerful strike can be
delivered if I draw back first like this
I honestly think you get a more solid
strike if you keep both hands locked on
there and you drive the weapon in but I
still teach sue bet and I'd like to bet
because I think it has another function
altogether does a couple great things
one thing is Sabet does a great job of
putting my tip back online so if I'm
here with this guy and he were to knock
my tip off line by drawing it back I
immediately get it back on target so
meaning that if I don't submit I have to
pull the tip back this way which is a
lot of work but if I simply use svet I
draw the tip right back on line another
things today is good for is clearing
anything so let's say he's pushed my
weapon to the side like this I don't
have to go up and around or anything
else I can use submit to get myself
right back online so if we were in some
kind of like say he's in the Khimki mine
and he pushes me off to the side like
this
hey wait does this I can use OOP
to get in here and set back up with this
guy immediately right so I can clear my
weapon with it really nice another thing
which is super useful is that can be
highly highly deceptive with my Sabet
and that's why I think the greatest
function of sube is quite honestly one
thing is from the svet position I can
now strike high mid or low with almost
no change and if he's just focusing on
my front hand there's really no
difference between that and that right
so very very deceptive I also can mess
with the timing of my strikes when I
strike with two hands on very directly
like this
the weapons either going forward or not
going forward however when I Sabet I can
now mess with him so it's a feint right
I've set him up to mess with his timing
so he doesn't know what's going on and
the last the most useful deception so
that is to change the length of the
weapon so I can come in here and say
with again and gosh use the sub X to
change the length of my weapon almost
instantaneously so this action of Sabet
is super useful not because it makes
some kind of mythical magical power or
something right keep two hands on the
weapon and drive straight in if you want
to have the most powerful strike however
if you want to be deceptive or quickly
reset your weapon then super is a great
tool to have in your arsenal and I
recommend practicing it in that way and
not just practicing it as a precursor to
ski every single time this is a soup